wie deutschland auf putins angriffskrieg
in der ukraine reagiert ist eine
fundamentale kehrtwende in der deutschen
außenpolitik da passieren dinge die
werden vor kurzem noch undenkbar gewesen
deutschland liefert waffen an die
ukraine es rüstet seine bundeswehr auf s
beteiligt sich ein härtesten
finanzsanktionen im kern geht es um die
frage ob macht das recht brechen darf ob
wir es putin gestatten die uhren
zurückzudrehen in die zeit der
großmächte des neunzehnten jahrhunderts
oder ob wir die kraft aufbringen
kriegstreibern nikotin grenzen zu setzen
in diesem insel politics geht es darum
wie die deutsche politik quasi in einer
nacht eine 180 grad wende seiner politik
vollzieht es geht darum welche rolle
china in diesem krieg in dieser krise
spielt und schliesslich was das alles
für uns bedeutet wie das nun weitergehen
[Applaus]
also was passiert da gerade die deutsche
zustimmung zur waffenlieferung an die
ukraine und gravierenden
finanzsanktionen gegen russland kommen
spät klar aber immerhin sie kommen und
das bedeutet eine grundlegende
neuausrichtung deutsche außenpolitik das
ist eine art fukushima moment für
deutschlands diplomatie so ähnlich wie
damals der atomausstieg nach dem
atomdesaster in japan deutsche politiker
waren in den letzten tagen fassungslos
darüber dass putin diesen angriffskrieg
kühl kalkuliert hat wir sind fassungslos
angesichts dessen was der ukraine was
den menschen in der ukraine erneut
angetan wird aber wir sind nicht
ohnmächtig und damit endet für
deutschland auch das besondere
verhältnis zu russland und damit das
erbe der nachwendezeit sozusagen die
dankbarkeit gegenüber russland dass die
deutsche einheit möglich war scholz und
die bundesregierung vollziehen diesen
schritt in eine situation in der sie
erst mal fast schon isoliert im westen
da standen jeder hat sich gefragt was
machen die deutschen eigentlich warum
kommen die nicht zu potte jetzt mit
diesem entscheidenden schritten hat sich
deutschland eingereiht in die antike
tina lienz trotzdem zwei vom tisch es
gibt waffenlieferung an die ukraine
russische banken werden aus trifft
ausgeschlossen und vor allem das
russische vermögen im ausland der
russischen zentralbank wird eingefroren
sehr bald wird die russische führung
spüren welchen preis sie bezahlt das
alles sind schritte die noch vor kurzem
undenkbar schien ja sie kommt spät aber
immerhin sie kommen und noch mal sie
sind eine zäsur
waffenlieferung zb da war deutschland
immer kategorisch dagegen aus zwei
gründen vor allem erstens deutsche
waffen haben in der ukraine und in
russland unbeschreiblich vielleicht
schon angerichtet in der nazizeit der
zweite grund es war klar dass deutsche
politiker scholz berbalk immer noch die
hoffnung hatten wenn deutschland keine
waffen liefert dass es dann
möglicherweise diplomatisch mehr
erreichen kann bei putin und sie haben
natürlich viel versucht aber was sie
nicht ahnen konnten ist das putting
tatsächlich überhaupt kein interesse an
einer diplomatischen lösung hatte wir
haben erst bis zuletzt ist zur letzten
minute mit diplomatie versucht ich
erinnere mich an ein gespräch mit
annalena baerbock bei einer nahostreise
in jerusalem das war mitte februar
und es ging um die lieferung von habitzl
aus ddr beständen die estland gerne als
waffenhilfe an die ukraine liefern
wollte damals galt noch die alte maxime
deutschland will keine waffen liefern
und deswegen war klar die zustimmung zur
freigabe für die haubitzen würde lange
sehr lange dauern im fußball würde man
sagen zeit spielen das alles hat sich
jetzt fundamental verändert solche
gespräche dieses hinauszögern das wird
es nicht mehr geben das ist jetzt vorbei
wenn unsere welt ein andere ist dann
muss auch unsere politik eine andere
sein und übrigens die haubitzen die
werden jetzt geliefert
die finanzsanktionen gegen russland zu
denen deutschland sich jetzt durchringt
die sind möglicherweise noch der tiefere
einschnitte us waffenlieferungen eine
weile schien deutschland wieder bremsen
zu sein wie ein land das angesichts der
existenziellen bedrohung von freiheit
und leben in der ukraine erst mal an
sich selbst und an seinen wohlstand
denkt jetzt werden aber auslandsvermögen
der russischen zentralbank eingefroren
trifft der zahlungsdienstleister
zwischen banken wird für russische
banken eingeschränkt allerdings das
haben die deutschen schon durchgesetzt
rohstofflieferungen so gas öl und kohle
aus russland die kann man weiterhin
bezahlen so viel eigennutzen wir dann
schon wichtig und trotzdem was da jetzt
beginnt ist eine neue epoche es ist das
ende der nachwendezeit das erbe
deutscher politik unter gerhard schröder
und angela merkel gegenüber russland
aber auch china war eine naivität
gegenüber deren aggressive außenpolitik
das ging einher mit dem fokus auf gute
geschäfte speak softly and carry
also den großen geldbeutel das war so
was wie die abwandlung des hospitals und
ein leitmotiv deutscher politik auch das
ist jetzt vorbei
und noch etwas ist neu wenn olaf scholz
100 milliarden extra für die bundeswehr
verspricht dann ist das etwas wirklich
wirklich groß angesichts der zeitenwende
die putins aggression bedeutet lautet
unser maßstab was für die sicherung des
friedens in europa gebraucht wird das
wird getan ihr müsst euch vorstellen pro
jahr hat die bundeswehr hat das
verteidigungsressort im moment rund 50
milliarden euro zur verfügung das ist
schon richtig richtig viel und ist in
den letzten jahren stark angestiegen
allerdings
ursprünglich war geplant dass diese 50
milliarden über die nächsten jahre auch
weniger werden um 34 milliarden ungefähr
jetzt also kommen 100 milliarden neue
hinzu das ist eine reaktion auf putin
und in gewisser weise auch eine vorsorge
für die zukunft wenn keiner weiß was
2024 zb passiert denn wie der
präsidentschaftswahlen sind was wäre
wenn donald trump dann wieder präsident
ist und die usa möglicherweise nicht
mehr zur verteidigung europas zur
verfügung stehen das alles spielt eine
rolle und das alles teil dieses tiefen
tiefen einschnitt den wir gerade erleben
und was ist eigentlich mit china welche
rolle spielt peking ich glaube china
hofft dass es der eigentliche nutznießer
und gewinner dieser krise ist viele
glauben ja es gäbe sozusagen eine
natürliche allianz zwischen russland und
china ich glaube da nicht so richtig
dran ich war fünf jahre lang
korrespondent in peking und es gibt im
wesentlichen nur zwei punkte die putin
und chipping china staats- und
parteichef 1 der erste ist beide halten
den niedergang der sowjetunion das ende
des kommunismus dort für einen
katastrophalen historischen fehler zu
den china alles damit es dort nicht
passiert und putin klar der versuch
diesen fehler zu revidieren der zweite
punkt der sie eint sie haben eine
paranoide angst vor freiheit und
demokratie und glauben dass ihr system
des autoritären den gästen überlegen so
die zwei punkte aber das war es im
grunde auch schon das ist jetzt keine
super starke allianz was bedeutet das es
bedeutet dass china nicht bereit sein
wird für russland die kohlen aus dem
feuer zu holen im gegenteil china hat
angst dass es ebenfalls von sanktionen
des westens betroffen sein könnte was
ist hofft ist dass die westlichen
sanktionen russland quasi von selbst den
pekings armut treibt und in eine
abhängigkeit von china dann
wäre china wirklich der gewinner der
lachen die dritte sozusagen in dieser
schweren schweren krise
die unterstützung aus deutschland der
ganzen welt das hilft den menschen in
der ukraine vielleicht nicht unmittelbar
aber es zeigt dass zum beispiel
deutschland die bundesregierung am ende
doch die richtigen schlüsse gezogen hat
im moment sieht es so aus als liefe
russlands vormarsch bei weitem nicht so
schnell wie putin sich das vorgestellt
haben dürfte für putin könnte der krieg
sogar zu einem afghanistan werden zu
einem desaster dass seine eigenen
machtposition bedroht das macht die lage
anders herum natürlich hoch gefährlich
deshalb droht putin jetzt sogar mit
atomwaffen dass diese nukleare bedrohung
wieder dass das zeigt was für eine
zeitenwende wir gerade erleben und all
die unsicherheiten mit dem wir jetzt
leben müssen im kalten krieg vor 1989
halfen am ende abschreckung und
diplomatie vielleicht auch diesmal aber
ehrlich gesagt viele fragen kann im
moment niemand beantworten nur soviel
kann ich euch versprechen wir bleiben
bei inside politics weiter dran und wenn
ihr fragen oder ideen habt schreibt sie
uns